dear fellow scholars this is two minute
papers with dr carol jonaife
today we are going to burn some virtual
trees
this is a fantastic computer graphics
paper from four years ago
i ask you to hold on to your papers
immediately
and do not get surprised if it
spontaneously lights on fire
yes this work is about simulating wood
combustion
and it is one of my favorite kinds of
papers that takes an
extremely narrow task and absolutely
nails it everything we can possibly ask
for
from such assimilation is there each
leaf has its own individual mass
and area they burn individually
transfer heat to their surroundings and
finally
branches bend and lock can eventually
even break
in this process
if we look under the hood we see that
these trees are defined
as a system of connected particles
embedded within
a physics simulator these particles have
their own properties
for instance you see the temperature
changes here
at different regions of the tree as the
fire gradually
consumes it now if you have been holding
on to your papers
squeeze that paper and look what do you
think
is this fire movement pre-programmed
it doesn't seem like it this seems more
like some real-time mouse movement
which is great news indeed and yes
that means that this simulation and all
the interactions we can do with it
runs in real time
here is a list of the many quantities it
can simulate
oh my goodness there's so much yummy
physics here
i don't even know where to start let's
pick the water content here
and see how changing it would look
this is a tree with a lower water
content
it catches fire rather easily
and now let's pour some rain on it then
afterwards look it becomes much more
difficult to light on fire
and emits huge plumes of dense dense
smoke
and we can even play with these
parameters in real time
we can also have a ton of fun by
choosing non-physical parameters for the
breaking coefficient
which of course can lead to the tree
suddenly falling apart
in a non-physical way the cool thing
here
is that we can either set these
parameters to physically plausible
values
and get a really realistic simulation
or we can choose to bend reality in
directions that are in line with our
artistic vision
how cool is that i could play with this
all day so as an experienced scholar you
ask
ok this looks great but how good
are these simulations really are they
just good enough to fool the untrained
eye
or are they indeed close to reality
i hope you know what's coming because
what is coming is my favorite part
in all simulation research and that is
when we let reality be our judge
and compare the simulation to that this
is a piece of real footage of a piece of
burning wood
and this is the simulation
well we see that the resolution of the
fire simulation was a little limited
it was four years ago after all however
it runs very similarly to the real-life
footage
bravo and all this was done in 2017.
what a time to be alive but we are not
even close to be done yet
this paper teaches us one more important
lesson
after publishing such an incredible work
it was accepted to the siggraph asia
2017 conference
that is one of the most prestigious
conferences in this research field
getting a paper accepted here is
equivalent to winning the olympic gold
medal of computer graphics research
so with that we would expect that the
authors now
revel in eternal glory right
well let's see what
is this serious the original video was
seen
by less than a thousand people online
how can that be and the paper was
referred to
only 10 times by other works in these
four years
now you see that is not so bad in
computer graphics
at all it is an order maybe even orders
of magnitude smaller field
than machine learning but i think this
is an excellent demonstration
of why i started this series and it is
because i get so
excited by this incredible human
achievements
and i feel that they deserve a little
more love than they are given
and of course these are so amazing
everybody has to know about them
happy to have you fellow scholars
watching this and celebrating these
papers with me
for more than 500 episodes now thank you
so much
it is a true honor to have such an
amazing and receptive audience
this episode has been supported by
weights and biases
in this post they show you how to use
their tool to fool
a neural network to look at a pig and be
really sure that it is an airliner if
you work with learning algorithms on a
regular basis
make sure to check out weights and
biases their system is designed to help
you organize your experiments
and it is so good it could shave off
weeks or even months of work from your
projects
and is completely free for all
individuals academics
and open source projects this really is
as good as it gets
and it is hardly a surprise that they
are now used by over 200 companies
and research institutions make sure to
visit them through wnb.com
papers or just click the link in the
video description
and you can get a free demo today our
thanks to weights and biases for their
long-standing support
and for helping us make better videos
for you thanks for watching and for your
generous support
and i'll see you next time